>> Laura: I AM LAURA INGRAHAM,
AND THIS IS A SPECIAL EDITION OF
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE," A WEEK IN
AN HOUR WHEN WE EXAMINED THE
STORIES THAT MADE THESE PAST FEW
DAYS FROM BIDEN AND COMMON THE
ABROAD FAUCI AND THE MEDIA BACK
HOME.
I'M GOING TO TAKE A LOOK BACK AT
THE BIG COMEBACKS OF THAT WEEK
FROM THE CINEMATIC TO THE
POLITICAL.
RAYMOND ARROYO WILL!
IT IN FRIDAY FOLLIES.
BUT FIRST, WHO SAYS THERE WAS A
NEWS AND HISTORY MADE OF THE G-7
IN CORNWALL?
WHO SAID BIDEN DID NOT IMPRESS?
AT LEAST ONE BIDEN DID.
AMERICA'S FACING A SERIES OF
REAL AND MAJOR CHALLENGES.
WE HAVE CHINA'S HUGE MILITARY
BUILDUP AND THE CRUSH OF
HUMANITY ENTERING OUR COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
AND OUR MEDIA CHOOSES TO FOCUS
ON WHETHER JILL'S LOVE JACKET IS
REALLY JUST A MELANIA TRUMP --
THE FORMER FIRST LADY WORE A
JACKET OF HER OWN IN 2018 THAT
DROVE THAT LEFT NUTS.
LISTEN.
IT WAS AN EXCELLENT TROLL.
SHE IS SENDING A MESSAGE OF
LOVE, REUNIFICATION.
>> I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT UP THE
JACKET.
IT IS HARD TO IMAGINE THAT THAT
WAS ANY SORT OF COINCIDENCE.
DON'T ARE CLOTHES SPEAK FOR US?
>> Laura: WELL, THE PRINT
HEADLINES.
USA TODAY CALLED JOE'S JACKET A
SYMBOL OF UNITY -- JILL'S JACKET
A SINGLE OF UNITY.
CNN CLAIMS JOE BIDEN'S LEFT
BLAZER SETS THE TONE OF THE G7
SUMMIT.
NOW, THE ONLY NEWS.
REALLY COME OUT OF THE G7 IS
THAT OUR ALLIES LIKE BIDEN AS IN
JOE MORE THAN TRUMP.
UNLIKE THE FORMER PRESIDENT, OLD
JOE WOULD BE SUBMITTED AND NOT
REALLY REQUIRE ANYTHING OF OUR
ALLIES.
OF COURSE, HE WILL TOTALLY
IGNORE AMERICA'S NATIONAL
INTERESTS IN FAVOR OF GLOBAL
CONCERNS.
THE ENTERIC CONTACT HUGE WASTE
OF TIME.
AT TIMES, JUST PLAIN GOOFY,
RIGHT DOWN TO AWKWARD WALK TO
THE OUTSIDE PLATFORM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> President Biden: WHICH WAY
ARE WE GOING?
ALL RIGHT.
>> PROBABLY IN THE MIDDLE.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> President Biden: ALL RIGHT.
>> Laura: IS JOE CONFUSED
ABOUT WHERE TO LOOK THERE?
DON'T YOU LOVE THE IDIOTIC ELBOW
BUMP OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
OUTSIDE AND HAVE ALREADY GOTTEN
THE VACCINE?
IT IS ALL THEATER AT THIS POINT.
BUT THE REAL ACTION THIS WEEK
WAS NOT WITH POTUS, BUT WAS THE
POTUS.
COM A HARRIS HAS RUN INTO THE
BUS SAW THAT SHE HAS BEEN
AVOIDING.
IT IS CALLED REALITY AND HAVING
TO ANSWER SERIOUS QUESTIONS
ABOUT A REAL, REAL PROBLEM, THE
BORDER CRISIS WHICH BIDEN
FOISTED ON HER TO ADDRESS BUT
INSTEAD IT HAS JUST BECOME A
MESS.
AND THAT RHYMES.
BY THE VACANT HARRIS IS SHOWING
SIGNS OF CRACKING.
>> Vice President Harris: WE
HAVE BEEN TO THE BORDER.
WE HAVE BEEN TO THE BORDER.
>> YOU HAVE NOT BEEN TO THE
BORDER.
>> Vice President Harris: AND
I HAVE NOT BEEN TO EUROPE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE POINT
THAT YOU ARE MAKING.
>> WILL YOU DO IT SOON?
>> Vice President Harris: YES,
I WILL.
>> WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO THE
BORDER VICE PRESIDENT?
>> Vice President Harris: I'M
NOT FINISHED.
I SAID I'M GOING TO THE BORDER.
>> Laura: DID YOU NOTICE THAT?
I'M NOT FINISH.
LET ME FINISH.
IT IS SORT OF LIKE A PUNCTUATION
MARK OF DESPERATION FOR
COMMON-LAW.
>> I MENTIONED YOU WERE
SURROUNDED BY A TEAM OF FOLKS
WHO HELPED PREPARE YOU.
>> Vice President Harris: I
HAVE --
>> LET ME FINISH.
>> Vice President Harris:
EXCUSE ME.
I'M ASKING THE QUESTIONS.
>> I'M SPEAKING.
I'M SPEAKING.
>> MR. VICE PRESIDENT, I'M
SPEAKING.
>> Laura: THE FACT IS,
EVERYONE IS STARTING TO SEE WHAT
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY VOTERS KNEW
ABOUT TOM WILL HARRIS.
SHE IS JUST NOT A PRIME TIME
PLAYER.
SHE HAS NO RELEVANT EXPERIENCE
AND SHE IS TOTALLY IN OVER HER
HEAD.
>> Vice President Harris: THE
PRESIDENT AND I ALSO DISCUSSED
THE ROOT CAUSES OF MIGRATION,
THE ROOT CAUSES AND THE CUTE
CAUSES AND DO IT WITH THOSE.
THERE ARE MANY FACTORS AT PLAY
WHEN WE LOOK AT MIGRATION
HISTORICALLY AND CURRENTLY.
THE ISSUES THAT ARE
LONG-STANDING BY VIRTUE OF THAT
NATURE OF THEM ARE NEVER GOING
TO BE SOLVED OVERNIGHT.
WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
COMPLEXITY OF IT.
>> Laura: OH, MY GOD.
THAT IS TERRIFYING.
THAT IS SORT OF GLIB BROMIDE
LADEN SERIES OF GENERALITIES
THAT YOU MAY BE ABLE TO GLIDED
BY IN THE U.S. SENATE.
BUT IT DOES NOT WORK WHEN YOU
WERE ON THAT WORLD STAGE IN
CHARGE OF HANDLING SERIOUS
ISSUES.
NOW, THINGS HAVE GOTTEN SO BAD
FOR VP HARRIS THAT SHE EVEN HAD
CNN WORRIED.
>> THAT WAS AN EASY QUESTION.
THAT WAS A QUESTION THAT THE
VICE PRESIDENT WAS GOING TO GET.
>> SHE DISMISSED IT IN A WAY
THAT WAS NOT REALLY RESPONSIVE.
IT WAS NOT SATISFACTORY.
ASSIGNED THAT SHE HAS A LEARNING
CURVE IN THIS NEW JOB PROSPECT
WHEN SHE DOES NOT LIKE A
QUESTION THAT SHE GETS THAT SHE
OFTEN DEFLECTS INCHOATE THAT CAN
THAT CAN SEEM DEFENSIVE.
>> Laura: YOU THINK?
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT MOMENT IS
THAT IT LOOKS LIKE THE BIDEN
WHITE HOUSE IS BEGINNING TO HAVE
A GROWING CASE OF VIRUS REMORSE
-- BUYERS' REMORSE ABOUT PARIS.
>> IT IS NO SURPRISE THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE WAS NOT THRILLED BY
THAT ANSWER.
THERE.
OFFICIALS WHO WERE PERPLEXED
WITH HOW SHE ANSWERED QUESTIONS
THAT SHE SHOULD HAVE KNOWN WERE
COMING.
>> Laura: THEY ARE LEAKING
ABOUT HER.
NOT A GOOD SIGN.
IF THE WOMAN GETS.
LEAF WHEN ASKED A SIMPLE OBVIOUS
QUESTION, HOW IN THE HECK IS SHE
GOING TO DO WHEN SHE SITS ACROSS
THE TABLE FROM LET'S SAY CHINESE
OR RUSSIAN COUNTERPARTS?
HOW IS GOING TO WIN FOR AMERICA?
MAYBE WE ARE BEING TOO HARD ON
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS.
THE BORDER ISSUE IS SERIOUS AND
ALL.
IS IT REALLY ABOUT LIFE AND
DEATH?
I DON'T KNOW.
YOU BE THE JUDGE.
>> MY JUDGES ARE ASKING FOR 1
THING IN PARTICULAR.
IF I COULD DO ONE THING FOR YOU,
WHAT WOULD THAT BE?
THIS IS THE -- THEY GO, TONY, WE
NEED MORE BODY BAGS.
WHAT YOU NEED BODY BAGS?
THEY GO, MIGRANTS ARE DYING AT
RECORD NUMBERS.
AND WE DON'T HAVE BODY BAGS TO
HANDLE THE SITUATION.
>> Laura: WOW, THIS IS ONE OF
THAT MANY REASONS HARRIS IS NOT
RUSHING TO VISIT THE BORDER.
WHAT IS SHE GOING TO SAY IF SHE
IS ASKED ABOUT THIS?
IS THIS OKAY WITH HER?
IF NOT, WHAT DOES SHE PLAN TO DO
WITH IT?
TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG CABOT STATED
HIS VIEW ON WHAT THEIR REAL
MOTIVE IS.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THIS IS
PURPOSEFUL ON THE PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION, ALLOWING THIS
MANY PEOPLE TO COME INTO OUR
COUNTRY?
>> I FEEL CERTAIN THAT IT IS
WILLFUL.
IT IS PURPOSEFUL.
IT IS DISREGARD FOR THE BORDER
LAWS.
>> Laura: THE ADMINISTRATION
HERE IS IN A REAL BIND PICTURE,
THE BORDER IS A TOTAL NIGHTMARE
AND EVERYONE KNOWS IT AND IT IS
CAUSING BIDEN'S NUMBERS ON
IMMIGRATION TO TAKE.
BUT WORSE IS THE FACT THAT FOR
EVERY CHALLENGE FACING AMERICA,
BIDEN'S JOE'S NUMBER TWO IS
SIMPLY INCAPABLE OF DOING HER
JOB AT THE LEVEL IT NEEDS TO BE
DONE.
HOW IS THIS GOING TO PLAY OUT?
BADLY, THAT IS HOW.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
DIVERSITY IS VALUED MORE THAN
MERIT AND ACCOMPLISHMENT.
THEY HAD TO KNOW SHE WAS NOT UP
TO THE TASK AND THEY CHOSE HER.
THIS IS FROM THE NEW YORK TIMES
IN NOVEMBER IN 2019.
THAT WAS THEIR TITLE.
VERSUS ONE OF THE WORST
CAMPAIGNS MARKED BY INFIGHTING.
IT WAS ACTION UNLESS AND HARRIS'
SISTER IT WAS A MIDDLING
OPPORTUNIST.
IT SEEMS LIKE EVERYONE ON THE
STAFF WAS MISERABLE.
IF COM1 HARRIS BELLY FLOPS GET
THIS SPECTACULAR LEAP IN HER
FIRST SIX MONTHS AS VICE
PRESIDEN